dear Bangkok Thailand I'm represent my
suppose that oh man yeah I got that boom
anyway we got goop a continuing right
now
me versus neuroma NIEM neuroma arson ash
all tied one and work one in this group
stage so far it's a round-robin format
of course this point all son is locked
himself in he's gonna be emerging from
this group right and but I only locked
out yeah
but out of those three players that you
just mentioned no Roma me arson ash only
one is going to be able to make it out
of group stage this unit that's crazy
what shadows still has a role to play
here cuz he still has to play against
ours and that he can definitely play
spoiler
big-time spoiler so they're setting up
with a match right now we're gonna have
me versus no Roma this is a very
important match as well you know neuroma
as we mentioned tied with me 1-1 you
know taking the lead here it's huge if
knee goes down here then what does that
even mean
does anybody has to meet our sling yeah
I mean it would it would force that's to
it like just with the way the numbers
are right now everyone every win is
still important for you mmm-hmm so here
we go looks like they're all locked in
character lock game is loading up Korea
vs. Japan it's a three-way tie right now
man mining for survival fighting for
your life right here is no Romo Korea
for Japan and he goes back to Jack Jack
versus Paul Phoenix precipice of fate
the stage title is appropriate go to Big
Machine and the Phoenix your knees warm
up all his characters keeping the
rotation fresh alright right off the bat
launch from me and just like that the
we'll find a 55% back to the wall didn't
even know he was gonna use Jack with any
big ball out or yelling or before I have
no idea I'm just something trying to
size that left gets caught by the
uppercut the Romanov was chance plug
free
there's down back ones slowpokes dealing
with them so well keeping that range
there was to throw Wow broken that angle
was wrong you would pin wall splat big
down for changes we had up and did it
great football oh my god it was a good
call outs alright if you blocked it then
you get the wall you get the wall chip
no Roma though you still would've had
advantage with manna lucky break
watching this I'm upset that he was even
using Dragunov yeah you don't like it
have a little faith in your in your mate
it was one round I'm like this guy's
jack is sad cross dump truck enter for
for one trying to lock without these
jackhammers sweep for damn girl oh god I
got the time sidestep look these defense
holding up hit the dead fish nice Oh
rarely uses deafness in the open back up
bow the buckets back for the one dolls
definitely a mistake you definitely
trying to like back that's a jab or
something big-time mistake there and it
cost them
hammer this hammer fist and then write
it to another neuroma well-placed
uppercut he's down for two siffredi
because again Paul Paul kinloch 20s back
three to fourteen frame launcher mm-hmm
with its range is really good return but
like you said if it carries a very very
big risk of agate all day yo these
deficit on point the low create your own
point to knee off the hope Harry one so
no man yep definitely underrated right
Paul's throw game is so strong he's got
every objet dedicated brakes got a she
drives open jack though no slots in that
same compartment dump truck once again
however I feel like these lot every
first game today like I said right down
Lewis needs about again look you you
won't see no packet loss there's a
little bit but you give him this long
set you give him this first two tooth
this person to me that's what things
start settling he gets a sense for your
timing that's why you want to move and
his often changes up in response fishing
with the uppercut and hung there's not
even trying to punish back three that's
the fourteen people watch football
bing-bang-boom
uh-huh and me quickly answer it back
that's the momentum swing we were
talking about this is the start of it
said not even optimal punishes here role
it's about control them how is he
fighting though you know it's so crazy
that neuromas thrown out so me down poor
choose in general look at the damage on
that combo hammer attorneys the guard
stuff to be able to force his way off
the wall but then it just look another
sidestep left
mmm-hmm and try it again this oh my god
he caught him on his break and he'll
take that trait all day
damn nice plate crispy right now hi Paul
I love it hot ticket down what do you
see Paul Hawking
every other possibility shredder kicked
something oh man oh dude you kid need
you trying to see you piss blood your
robot blood
oh damn side left hop kick with the
Phoenix all the way to the wall give me
a big boy Cup oh the dead bit that's a
big best big enough mm-hmm Salah makes a
jabs and lows here from neuroma got me
to the wall
oh these ducts he looks up Lopes like
damn back ones right if you want D [ __ ]
no brain that time they're all up trying
to stay in this game no packet lost baby
what a piece and you saw yet especially
at the close range like that when we
talking about the dots looking for the
probably looking for raves dry probably
looking for rays drive over down back
one of that said that scenario the Roma
delayed it held onto it for just a
little while didn't matter though me at
the very end able to close without
thinking that clutch gang get soon and
then the interaction after after the
frame event and neuromas hit so many
down for twos but need even be dunking
it was like yeah like he's like he's
like challenging you play yeah you
showed no fear do you like it
point-blank range or a lot of times to
which obviously again again the ball
carries all this especially with your
back to the wall that's crazy
and now immediately switching off of
Jack going to dragging up so his Jack
gets him a game
alright that could be huge here alright
game 3 coming up and these guys are tied
in the round-robin do you want to make
the top eight they gotta get a W here
yep this is this is another important
game an important set rather mmm-hmm
the clown is back
no smiles don't man hmm where the hell
does the ball come from man pausing the
construction you know
right now it rains control for an aroma
but to read me off the slow Perry the
clock got taken yet even on health
Demoman now starting to do some more
exercise to gets this low yeah the
Phoenix is definitely warmed up right
now
solid dominant first round for me and if
you're some of the other players in this
group that you sing a lot starting to
start get hot with multiple characters
at this point you don't know what's
gonna be coming your way down or hitting
the pickup huh
we'll have the gods pressure put me with
the low pay a little bit early that time
despite your step
subtle tracking real Harper that's way
back for the [ __ ] pressure now while
standing for get out of Dodge three for
three
yeah and the wall carrier doesn't quite
reach though opportunity but no its way
back to and just like that it is gonna
be set point for knee
fans in the crowd ready to go hockey no
one point from neuroma forget the down
forward to return off his uppercut here
- 50% but neuroma you gotta be able to
hold this position me right off the bat
micro step right out of Dodge now
parallel to the wall not gonna get that
wall bounce she hasn't even done it
right we've seen so many mass was
backing up that's the first time we've
seen the wall said I want three out of
them
you're in a room of fighting back here
good makes it down for once in the ninth
floor hope damage add it up right there
but D right now set point
you'll count it and the back will put
some step on them
another right back no no boy counter it
down back your knees this time this is
gonna hurt no job the company get the
ones into in-between it's the one with
the round that's huge
final final round a robot versus me and
it's important it is super important way
to pull the trigger on that with low
very big bang boom no oh there in the
wall I'll arrange this is war stage
where this becomes very important
because the way the cameras do oh man
the counter is ready to accept rate vote
me twice compactable not gonna happen
me gets it done and get the victory over
neuroma what no Matt no given up with
these guys man me in a row but these
guys are playing their hearts out right
now Sony now puts himself in position at
this point two in one no Roma Falls to I
believe one one and two
yeah I think so so now I'll get again
still that arson ash and Wilma set this
bar over to that one happen right track
here but either way take a look at the
standings room we could check it out
yes an aroma now with that one to me
advancing so he's highlighted there
right he's like top - yeah alright he's
in there what's not guaranteed yet we
slept
Arslan - has to play aroma wanted to a
little dicey for them but coming up next
we've got the mannequin play spoiler we
got shadow returning to the stage could
it be going up against redbull v / r /
Pakistan vs. USA here in Thailand and
even though you know at this point
shadow you know he came out here who's
able to compete Oh getting World Tour
Finals a huge accomplishment for him
this year I think oh yeah question you
Kapoor really saw a solid year
performance for him yeah you shot of
course disrupt gaming
helping shadow and both jr. get out to
all these events it clearly has level to
poke these players got their point a
huge improvement
mm-hmm and now shadow here at the finals
right now yet unfortunately locked out
at this point mm-hmm but like you said
can be a huge spoiler right here and I
feel like every single said he's had
here he's won the first go in the first
game and then just yeah just slowly gets
control of it taken away from him in the
game too so let's see what character
they want to go it and both these guys
have actually been using it but it's
Avena so maybe we don't season me
probably and in fact yeah we're gonna
see Keith and Claudio
so Arthur matched Kazuma didn't work out
from earlier geez did and now he's
sticking to the geese for now is this
gonna be the character he sticks with
for the rest of the tournament will we
see more Kazuma later we'll find out but
right now it's arson ash versus shadow
geese Howard versus claudio pigs
brimstone and fire and I started yeah I
was looking a little bit shaky that
early early on with this geese right
there first then again like you said a
little dab just a little bit cleaner as
as the set went on early no but again
shadow right now man you gotta come out
guns little guns blazing one gotta make
sure we get this win the shadow on the
other side trying to make a state
I'm like he knows like his run at top
aides ready over but if you want to win
right and a who better to get one on you
don't want to go out of your just the
goose egg
beautiful and if you could get this win
over Arsenal - make this crew stage a
lot more interesting range pokes ahead
upper shadow right now health fleet it
doesn't pull the trigger after whipped
waffle standing for yeah mister round
here come on 75% bar billed for our
smash - guard - guard - back away first
and there you go you saw I'm good using
the right shadow first game easy man
then change up on the other side too low
folks I just have to offset as well
setting one side step low Holmes hey
ward jab checks in the downpour one
pressure
oh man you let the whole thing rip this
finish it man and look at this quick -
around your shadow and called it mm-hmm
early on control fight it's something
about shadows play style you know give
every player a hard time the first under
vital
Marcin at the bar and a half-built Wow
three was headed a lot around the big up
for him just like that that's the start
right LOI Harry gonna get the wall he's
at the wall take the damage from the
double rep shadow content to just chill
need some jabs are some working on a
perfect still in this round not gonna
get it still gets to parts and the
hooking shadow just willing to just by
this time hold his guard final you want
to back off now I'm gonna step and look
at him just clip things around now
here's our thumbs back to the wall I
sliced up right top of the jab fishing
with him shadows in trouble of not
enough time on the clock and a jab float
here from arson ash not gonna be enough
to pose doubtful yet time gonna become a
factor here yeah even if people hate him
with every single law yet now it's not
not gonna happen that route is done our
salon of the board he knows he's like
yeah okay you can have that to continue
next round when you get sets like this
which so many rounds go to time I like
that because it's been so local middle
and the defense been so good on both
sides just as heavy poke game word every
hit feels so hard-earned the SWAC the
splat double wrap bomb could break it
what was to be done
- just order to save just jab that were
one pressure 1 1 2 again the stick into
the wall Oh order stem
that was a prep - Martha nice looking
fat tax right now doesn't get the full
wall combo though call it the first game
each time but right now arson is the one
who's swinging it back in this baby
ok here comes Chad Oh got a chance here
Oh an arsonist final round slowly
bringing it back yeah you can see the
confidence building an arson axe right
now and again this chat pressure this
jabs you just out more wanton rasp we're
gonna meet on the pressure this time
that's a win if your shadow to blow in
the punish yeah but I feel like shadows
getting bullied in terms of stays
positioning always right yeah this time
the run to get them out of there it's a
it's like it's guard is so good but it's
some putting them in back positions to
counter it down for me big return for
some national champions on take it again
nice 45% chunk right there and the low
kick again back three just burn the
gauge on the pressure at this point
so no meter here for 15 SEC's of chats
going here it is time backing it get
I'll give you the wall come through yeah
there's not enough time you oh my god
shadow no time how do you make that
happen
how yo the u.s. they crowded the Chan
right now and the expression on are some
ass right now you see is what I say boys
chanting USA in the ground oh no are you
guys he's a cuddler karate Judy out
there make you some noise no right Wow
so shadow I can't get the first game
look at arsons expression right now -
right mm-hmm
you haven't seen it looked like that you
know II spoke focus get the win man
that's a lot of pressure I would go to
the infinite stage here he's sticking it
out with jeez Howard like we were saying
before right it's not that big of a deal
of course because of the way the damage
conversion works for GCC jewelry but it
felt like a lot of a lot of the time and
that in that first game it was R / he
was the one benefiting from the wall
most of time I'm like in my head I'm
trying to figure out the tiebreaker
situation if Martin loses you who wins
his other sets you know I don't know how
that works out I feel like he's in a
must-win situation countour finally
something we have not seen go to yeah
not gonna be the biggest return right
because doesn't mean ER to give the
water rely on like we said earlier -
right just up the wall on the stage and
that's the thing right build that back
three that need a sudden we see shadow
go to Mike James to Game three etc to
establish tempo with the troll right
most characters can't calipari put
Kesey's cash
that's what arson is young
most of us worked up right here in this
rain with these jabs and down for once
that was a beautiful punch that would
fall to to rage mode now for both
players and of course of the shadow game
to shout around time winding down lock
and punish nice good crouch that cancel
they're so awesome with the first round
here
yeah Johnny he wants a side zipper there
fireballs get her running - for the whip
on she did it early though and I showed
his hand a little too fast down three
can just a very poke heavy deep berry
poke heavy match right now
guard stronger both sides the Maximo
confirm no for arson - look at the
damage it first is used to be where he
is we clear but now he does organize
he's the keys when he picked themselves
took 65% for one bar fine oh damn that's
gonna talk about right there man push a
recovery from the sugar candy though and
nice not not enough it would chop up his
tank ankles there three arson ass on
this infinite stage trying to make a
statement here trying to take us through
a game 3-1 bar pill side Carter be in
the hole man that was gorgeous just
barely clip the down for one there oh
okay
good movement from shadows just not
erasing those tabs - and while standing
for deal this jab now shadow walking
down these back threes he's like like
you think I'm gonna mix it up nah man
shadows still in Game two here speaking
the - man bottom left point of your
screen
mm-hmm two bars on deck you gotta
imagine arson ashes looking for the
first opportunity came to people try to
close it out try to use some of it low
parry from shadow though nothing after
oh man this is so tense rip oh and
that's why it doesn't usually do
Arzu style is so compact it doesn't
really give big opportunities and then
that situationnal the big opportunity
gave me shadow shadow took advantage now
arson has to go win yeah you know shadow
he's content to run away but I'm gonna
be sure people good use of the time
there's rock set point hello
big time I'm standing here potentially
in group stage
I mean spoiler please give out me a big
spoiler full meter for to eat the run
into those Superman Superman arson ants
with three bars to give the owner us a
crowd will be the burnt sub just on
pressure here Buchan Bartlett in trouble
three beds the raid always think this
pitches pentameter just a bar this
doesn't want to hold on to still has one
to give he's not out of this yet but
shadows defense right now he ain't
Buchman rip boom he's got a lot of time
there and you know arts got going shadow
is contended his back that's all day
he's gonna try to do some felony arson
trouble going to get the dope stand them
on to bring it back ten seconds on the
clock no pressure again it's not over -
he might have just a huge spoiler oh my
goodness he gets the W he's not big the
top baby yo give it up for shadow
twenties here
oh my god the entire set built up to
that so many rounds down to the very
last fit the very last few sequences in
exchanges oh my god can you believe what
just happened here I can't I can't see
it's crazy we've bounced it when it
feels like so many players this year
we've had we've had so few come up with
answers to arson on big stages like this
shadow emerges is the one that plays
spoiler in the final group stage like
this and maybe could have just played a
huge spoiler to this group he may have
just knocked our stand out of the topic
we got a look at it we got see how the
rest of the group plays out but that
lost right there may knock him out wow
that's craziness but here's another one
that's super important we've got old
song verses neuroma yes so it's pretty
so what has to happen is neuroma and
Roman has to know I was gonna say
neuroma has to win for him if Marcin -
if you're arson - you're hoping to Roman
loose of course yeah course you're
hoping he loses and then you put it on
your arson - person ISA be about her man
oh my god okay alright that's what we're
looking that's what we're looking at
right here no Roma at this point yeah he
controls his own destiny at this point
right mm-hm if he wins out how many
matches neuroma have he has old son he
has another oh no I think this is this
his last one is either or my help I
think he's one of two currently
yeah but let's hear what Norma had to
say about technical tour finals this
year call it the doctor was tentative
kiddo post essentially just to make it a
nice introductory jdz this year as for
the study oh I thought the homicidal
Mikey didn't know that well he had his
chance against me it was closed down to
the wire and that's it he got it though
and now he's got to go up against Ulsan
an Ulsan has been on fire today yes so
obviously that was one of his objectives
too because if you go back to norm and
he threw out the technical tour right
not just this year but last year as well
that was one thing that came up right he
was in to meet me and JD CR but he has
to be able to quickly forget that loss
and he's still playing for the spot at
this point right yes so he has to give
and quickly forget that you might get
another shot at him in toffee but you
got to get there first and you got to
get there you've got to be able to get a
win overall song right now so just a
couple more matches left in this group
stage before we figure everything out
right now it's gonna be neuroma versus
Ulsan I give another JP versus Korea
matchup the classic right mm-hmm I feel
like ever since the Roma went over them
beat them they're like we don't forget
that man we're prepared for you now it's
funny the way it the way it worked up
until this year - right you had Japan go
win in Korea
mm-hmm Korea coach Japan then you had
them run back okay Korea take defense
house this time mm-hmm now we go to
Japan and Pakistan's taking over right
they get yeah they beat most of the
commedia players on the bracket and then
the Pakistan players are there Japan can
take their own house it's rough man
but enrollment right now trying to make
a statement here gotta go in overall
Sandow dragged versus Qasimi white so
we're looking at get right off the bat
Ulsan forcing his offense here in wave
zero get just a lot of town poor ones a
lot of Japanese oh it's the same thing
we use the same oh yeah tons and look at
the backswing blow from Naraku be good
return here could carry
back out which at the wallet thinking of
Russian assault you offer your recovery
to put it down to just kidding Russian
assault and that's something we actually
haven't seen a ton out of neuroma right
it's primarily the down twos not a lot
of the Russian assaults out of them the
low Perry's wall carried no nice snap
just a little bit late on the trigger
yeah like attempt though just so hard
right those compact you have yeah
awkward once so hard with slits very
small windows you don't have a lot of
time look at the prick just keeping the
real close range zero not giving him any
space to breathe and no big swings
either right he's just content to just
chop away in this window one by one
yeah Oh son he's it's it's like he had
double it's from his group last night
last night and you prepared for
everybody right how does he is just so
prepared right now God once again
with this Walt image and that time run
stupid ones to down to will Walsh it
does ball sounds turn here though
catches her out of white in the perfect
quote an siRNA Roma takes that round
back
both these guys looking really focused
up there right now beautiful block and
punish their runs up down forward to and
that's like his jack styling out for
jail right now
one three with the bow soon you know
what time it is mm-hm and that game one
time that's what that was no Rome while
looking sharp and they nerfed the damage
on it but it stayed still we'll just get
it with a wall bounce in that scenario
it doesn't matter yeah that move is
ridiculous that's I mean if I was a
dragon off player I'll just be thrown
out like watch it boom to the start that
positive images for no reason it might
it does we oh man but in Rome again in
the first game old son gonna have to DAP
here and that's I feel like the first
have you seen is kazumi lose the first
game to set
yeah he's maybe the for me the first set
actually I won't cuz he had Bob yeah
yeah you're right
he took yet so Game one would lose
getting second game and then okay runner
in the game through right and been all
in well here we go this time Bulls on
fighting from behind with kazumi
infinite stages his choice here and he
seems to favor that right we talked
about previously in his that would need
or even though the wall look like
they're favoring and we'd still prefer
to go there yeah it's it's curious right
looking but that's a player preference
of course man they're almost blocks of
these lows have been on point damn just
looking a little bit sleepy early on but
ever since then right after that first
set or two mm-hmm his guard has really
really tight sidestepping punishment Wow
and the get would he stay down the rage
drive out of nowhere he's been had no
aroma
looking like he's gonna get this done
here
sidewalk down or to its calculate each
time he hasn't we know and also much
this way you might attack these high
strings I know though oh my god
everything working up in the room right
now this one yet
put the downpours to get the try to
close out down to cut those ankles up no
Romo on set point versus all song trying
to make a statement here the side step
right at close range boom pulse on now
with his jab pressure back it on up
counter hit down some runners to the
salt right back at you running thank you
my god this is beat down everything I'm
pointing aroma to to zero overall
thought so
so all son fishes this group three one
yes that means is that that I think are
some ashes at eyes Ilana I don't know
how this works I think by the numbers he
should be locked up right so it might be
between me and the row its might be
between me and or me already beat in a
row we got it we gotta see we gotta see
the lizard if I don't have a calculator
I'm not doing this no here's the
calculations years let's happen
we're freaking it out along with you
guys right now for right now we're down
to the last matchup in this group space
and that shadow set is an old man yeah I
mean look look at the look at the board
right now knees up there two-to-one the
role most below him due to to so this
means and Arthur Nash's wanted to so
this means me arson - if arts Lin - beat
beats they're all tied three-way tie
with - - yeah but I think it'll come
down to the matchups of what happened
when they played each other yes I think
so it does come down to this I think it
does all right maybe arson - you've been
a hell of a year man you started it off
evil Japan you went to Evo got it done
there you're at this tech and World Tour
final right here right now sitting down
against who I think everybody in the
world is looking at these two guys and
saying we want to see this we want these
in the water and you gotta fight for
your life right here right now but of
course guys we
did talk to me before his turn about
let's go ahead and give it a listen
talking to me I know there's someone
coming oh so the way this works okay we
just got word yes
the way this works is that if me wins
even a single game he locks our so now
arson ash has to win 2-0 over knee to
put himself in this conversation if he
does he's in to the top eight so both
players have their life on the line here
but the character selection rip and
that's the big question mark
you called it Paul Vorenus Qasimi oh boy
if knee can get one game he's into the
top eight arson has the two oniy in
tournament this is crazy I mean on
tournament stages he's if he's been able
to help lay him but this it feels a
little bit different right here right
now rare we go especially with the power
that this brothers packing shrinks in
return arson that has been on his mind
he said I've been thinking about you for
months already gets caught first
what do you say whenever something lair
who makes every other player feel like
they don't know how to play the game
and he runs into someone makes him feel
that way my question for knees what are
you gonna show us how have you changed
it gets you now we're new and pushing
arson ash towards the wall get just a
lot of good microstepping just go hard
marcin ash now and that will be round
number one fall off than that he's
trying to move back and come back board
and get a jab players getting back
forward one is the input light does he
have nerves he kept the doubt forward to
that doesn't even sound round I mean
this the plate cannot beat in tournament
get the walls out here is ready for the
Reece map oh hell it damaged psyche
defeat me get the poor buddy back
or reversed
and open-palm I didn't notice that
before and compared to when they were
playing the devil gene versus cosmic
matchup for this even the schemers Cosme
matchup where every hit felt so
hard-earned because of the firepower on
both sides of Sam it just feels like
there's melting each other's health bars
they say oh the damage
Rolling Thunder Rolling Thunder one two
three guys I need now with rage we've
seen this Paul do so much damage that
can't get so that low that Paul has at
that range the perfect would just leave
his complete in streams a bit that's
quite enough for old man yo arkla that
kid he makes happen
whoever he's gotta with - oh he's up in
his berth game backs way to want to talk
Sylvie's moving a little bit gives up
his turn when he tries to go step in low
that can't get sugar I can't even speak
right now this is crazy
the crowd kept them - nothing kept the
counter at this time wanting to put the
combo deck fist leaves are just out of
rage as fortunate for me this time yeah
one will clean it'll do it for him
especially with the wall as a what's the
drive out there got the block oh he's
got rage now though unbelievable aren't
the net get the part
gave me what is little spawn Todd if
arson ash wins this to zero
he's gonna get in over you me what is
your answer to this entire year of
competition right here right now instant
remants different answer it all comes
down to this one game the set doesn't
even matter it's this game right here
it's arsons jad pressure that's doing so
much work
throw get off me I don't know you like
that don't touch me actually for no
counter at Mars is not gonna hit a
button sites them right get the launch
easy walk on marinas they've met at the
Paul Phoenix takes to its 45% hammer
Larson knows what time it is now just
turn a micro step right yeah Michael
traffic right on out of there
circle around I've take the wall for
himself sweet great block she still got
hers hold it in a red dress gonna get
the round close out the death pit I
don't I don't know watch this belt
important rebound round important fund
watch the rounds of two rounds away from
denying your rifle ultimate victory this
year you know one of these guys is not
going to talk mate it's this game that
matters
yeah I'm back to spring well daddy up
movement is crazy
back and forth back and forth finally
some Rolling Thunder yeah caught me
trying to move to the wall just let me
show you ain't I defeat you like now I'm
Hannah might miss it yeah fine with the
walls in the window combo Arthas
building this round he's in trouble
though me one round away from booking
his ticket to the top eight god that's
huge bars that's a big opportunity he's
fighting back with his jabs now get in
that range against him he does good call
him win he wants to try to pull
something out big but again trying to
hold that control cuz that in this range
right here he's losing mm-hmm the threat
of game gets Utah to get the wall it's
not enough to kill one more chance our -
honestly Nash's tournament life is over
my god me the set ain't over yet with
that with one to one it's one to one
the set continues but me is gonna be the
one who's gonna go to the top eight Wow
crazy it came down the game
differentials like we were saying
earlier right right and we don't run the
set out we are let's see what happens
here but huge moment you got an agile
some of a huge victory mm-hmm
but apart the winds this is like you
still beat your terminal oh my gosh that
chat pressure on for me
and hammers hear sound for nice step
from arson - no wall and he tried to
throw it out there need not gonna bite
and it wasn't great rocks dragons me Wow
this beer is everybody dick that's right
came down to that rib that's crazy
the way the whole thing played out nice
reversal again on the tackle no magic
buddy with these tap the rig's every
time though Prince and darn at the wall
tiger there's no strikes around the
perfect okay yeah I can watch these guys
play checking all day let it run the
first device doesn't keep playing oh man
I hope we're right about the numbers
bundling that be reverse the Kent every
single time here three for three and
then the break action that's the first
that's the first thing you going and the
armory da Hockney
you know where we go all the way out
even max returning that time that's okay
so I'm gonna hold this again this
positioning back to the wall since dawn
in the follow-up step into realign arson
- run again keep these back to the wall
here is jab pressure oh I don't want to
hear none of it though no one leaves
drive able to get knee again set point
at this morning he did what he needed to
do but if the witness says also he hung
up right
definitely world victory on some level
oh definitely
he's got a decent chance of doing so
here behind in this round though
temple Kim works out reverse the long
trail and me back in this round here
down back to Parkland shop in this tree
straight in a rage aren't you gonna kiss
at the camps and go for the copper here
me gonna take the set man he put both
his arms up after that me get the gun
against ours with a two-to-one here he
said it yesterday I had I came to this
turn and I came to Thailand with
somebody on my mind and me going to the
topic but yo ladies and gentlemen please
make some noise for redbull beast like
Arthur Nash
this man is single-handedly flipped the
tech world on his head this year what
the timing is an incredible story that
you would have to be just corny as hell
to deny quite frankly mmm
you if you think this guy or anybody
else here needs to any sort of
validation for how incredible this story
was for this community in this game I
don't know what the hell you watching
man give it up for so that you can
actually make heli actually make some
noise for arson and definitely right now
man he's literally put their thing
around you know we see Paxton now huge
part of the tech scene all because of
what arson eyes did evil Japan evil
Vegas you know out here finally me
getting his revenge getting his run back
and it done in a turn it's only been a
thing for a couple years now but how
many people have even you know mark
man's been pushing the narrative of the
Triple Crown right
how many people have even come close to
even being able to pursue something like
that this guy came so close and it came
down it came down to games it came down
to just that and of course he picked it
is he said it man I came to Thailand oh
yeah no choice ain't no massage gonna
take my eyes off of you baby
yeah I got I got eyes for you he came in
punched the ticket and didn't he the
crazy part I've been we talked about
that we're looking at some of these
other players now at this point what is
your response to what these guys have
done this year
mm-hmm me able to finally get it in over
his right while you're on it turn the
format in turn my turn for me at first
to Wanda said as well right didn't have
to win the whole somebody did got it
done there knee played fantastic ulsan
also let's not forget know playing
ridiculous today is and you if you're
watching some from some of these other
groups you're looking at this beauty
this group a beam all song to be the one
emerging but you got to be looking at
all Sun right now you like
oh crap this kid played out of his mind
just now right and you know earlier this
year I mentioned earlier at BAM you know
Huestis blinks or jigs even going back
to damage ermine you want that turban as
well you know Ulsan is on fire right now
now you see it neat and Ulsan three and
one in this group they will be going to
the top eight later tonight $250,000
prize pool on the line here there's a
lot of thing there's a lot of things rip
this I can't believe we got to do that
that was that was fun as oh that was
super fun man oh my god what do we do
now is it Group B time ready I think
it's that time and I think we get me a
the queueing up the think the next one
so do us a favor guys go get something
to eat go get something to drink
we'll be back in just a little bit with
Group B marginal Vaman trip here we'll
catch you guys next time be good
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so the technical tour actually helps to
revitalize the community in many ways
like for example holding a lot of
different events from all over the world
especially with this new dojo system and
they've definitely gotten everyone
involved and everyone seems like a part
of twt so everyone's a lot more excited
about Tekken in that regard we kind of
have like a year-long story to tell and
a lot of different player story lines
lead up into this big event so I think
that's the most interesting thing about
the tour is just to follow along all
year where the players have gone and
what's been going on so I think what
this year the third year of the tour
it's been the most interesting one yet
with everything that's happened in the
world of Texas in this entire year there
are a lot of people who sponsor
participant players the one of them is
Gigi and Union and their many companies
who are investing in pakistan's so I
think it's all because of the world work
when the stand first stepped up when
come and he goes to tournaments he won
in 200g so it's a good opportunity for
Ferguson he's opened the gate for
Pakistanis suggesting this would be Sega
taking sky at the clinic they each
dictating they're taking a circuit to
the sea taking God Nakata suribabu
kabocha John I know they're not even the
most Kushina they were taking Jin se
como Salinas me
[Music]
taken to me means so much